Dragon Age executive producer mock Dara
posted a Twitter poll yesterday asking
would you play a dragon age tactics game
to which a lot of you replied with an
emphatic yes when asked by a Twitter
user what he meant by tactics and are
clarified that he met something along
the lines of franchises like XCOM and
fire emblem of course this doesn't
necessarily mean that a dragon age
tactics game is in the works but we know
it's something Bioware have on the brain
Dara went on to clarify in subsequent
weeks that should a tactics game go
ahead it would not be in place of the
main Dragon Age series and it would be
released as a full standalone game the
Dragon Age series is not a complete
stranger to a more tactical style of
gameplay as both the original game and
Inquisition allow you to play from a
top-down perspective in combat which
requires you to think more strategically
be sure to let us know if you'd play a
dragon age tactics game and for all the
latest on this story and everything else
that matters in gaming stay tuned to
GameSpot's
you